it seems like we can get very little
same discussion in mainstream media um
about the role for instance that
regulation plays and how to strike the
balance and you're so clear about it you
know of course we need to you know
protect the environment of course we
care about you know species and
extinction and disruptions to the
habitat but we also can't take six years
to build an overpass in new york city
it's just not going to be functional not
not and remain not in re retain an
economy that simultaneously serves the
needs of the people who are released
well off
because they're the ones who will pay
the price for those delays fundamentally
absolutely another way of saying that
jordan is all these delays and uh cost
it's
it's like a regressive tax right
in other words right it's a tax
economist would think about it as an
implicit tax that disproportionately
hurts the poor
[Music]
hi everybody i'm very pleased today to
have with me two people um dr rick
gettys it's the timing is really perfect
because the biden infrastructure bill
just
passed
and
dr gettys is an expert on infrastructure
development and so it's exactly a
propitious time to have this
conversation about the details
associated with infrastructure what it
is and how it might be renewed and what
obstacles there are and so forth and
he's a he's a well recognized expert in
this particular area he holds a joint
appointment in both the cornell brook
school of public policy and in the
economics department at cornell he's a
member of the graduate fields of systems
engineering regional science and
economics he's founding director of the
cornell program in infrastructure policy
he's also a non-resident scholar at the
american enterprise institute in
washington dc i suppose that puts him
somewhat to the right of center
and that's relevant for reasons we'll
find out later rick's research centers
on the funding financing and permitting
of major infrastructure projects his
publications have appeared in a variety
of academic journals including the
american economic review the journal of
regulatory economics the journal of
legal studies the journal of law and
economics and the journal of law
economics and organization among others
he's author of the 2011 american
enterprise institute book entitled the
road to renewal
private investment in u.s transportation
infrastructure he holds m.a and ph
degrees in economics from the university
of chicago and a bs in economics and
finance from towson state university and
i also have with me as a co-host today
greg hurwitz
greg was a student of mine at harvard
years ago and we've remained in close
touch ever since he's the new york times
number one international best-selling
officer of 23 thrillers including the
orphan x series his novels have won
numerous literary awards and have been
published in 33 languages
greg was a guest on this podcast it was
season four episode two in an episode
entitled build a better democrat and he
sits i would say center left and so we
have two viewpoints uh i don't exactly
know where i sit and many people have
many opinions about that
so but greg is also interested in policy
development and is influential in
his views are influential on the center
left let's put it that way and we spent
a lot of time discussing practical
issues including what might political
parties concentrate on reasonably
intelligently to pull the discussion
back to the moderate and productive
center and we figured that
infrastructure was definitely at least
in
at least in principle one of those
things that might be regarded as
non-objectionable and useful by people
on both sides of the political spectrum
assuming that they're not so extreme
that you can't just talk to them at all
so i invited greg today
for the same reason that i invited dr
gettys is i hope to learn something
about infrastructure development from
someone who spent his whole life
studying it and greg's here for exactly
the same reason and and so
thank you very much dr gettys for
agreeing to talk to us today and uh i'm
looking forward to it so how did you get
interested in like why infrastructure
for you and maybe you can lay out what
it is as far as you're concerned why
it's so crucial and what but also what
got you interested in it yeah
so so thank you jordan i'm i'm uh very
honored to be invited to uh to join the
show and and uh excited people are
talking about infrastructure
particularly with a policy
event i have to go way back in time
jordan i wrote a paper on the u.s postal
service back in college at towson state
now towson university in baltimore
and got interested in economics in
college and attended graduate school for
my master's that must have made you
possible popular with the girls hey that
concentrates
yeah just just really popular
with them but i wrote my dissertation
back in chicago on the regulation of
electricity
companies investor-owned electricity
companies so i was always interested in
regulation of industry and ended up sort
of writing in the area of uh electric
utility regulation and ownership
different ownership forms
in uh to deliver electricity and circled
back on the postal service in fact and
uh you know i talked to fordham in the
bronx before coming to cornell and
my my work at fordham focused on on
postal policy around the world and
postal regulation
and then uh jordan in the 0405 academic
year if we can go back that far
i was invited to join the council of
economic advisors in the white house as
a senior economist what's called a
senior economist and that year was uh
precipitous for infrastructure policy
because congress was passing a highway
reauthorization bill and that's actually
important for what just happened in
congress now
and what happens is every five or six
years congress reauthorizes spending out
of the federal highway trust fund so
every time you buy a gallon of gasoline
in the united states 18.4 cents goes to
the federal government if you buy diesel
fuel it's 24.4 cents and congress just
kind of stores that up in the highway
trust fund until it reauthorizes
spending out to the states
every five or six years so that year 0
405 was the safety lou that was the name
of the bill the safety lieu highway
bill
and the executive branch was asked to
weigh in at a whole set of issues
related to highways roads bridges
tunnels and it included things like
environmental permitting
tolling of the interstate highway system
or of other roads public-private
partnerships or private investment and
infrastructure which is the topic i
wrote the book on uh that you have
because you know the executive branch is
is being um hit with all sorts of policy
issues as a result of that jordan
president george w bush
invited me to be a member of a
commission that was created in the
safety lou highway bill we called
ourselves section 1909 commission
because that was the section it was
literally called the national surface
transportation policy and revenue study
commission
because the federal highway program
turned very interesting in the united
states started by president eisenhower
back in 56
greatly increased the uh federal gas tax
to pay for the design and construction
of the u.s
interstate highway system
but by the 90s it was largely complete
uh but the point was you know they're
still collecting the
gas and diesel fuel taxes and what's the
point of the program
if you're you know basically have a
complete system so the purpose of this
commission was to kind of study that
question and i got exposed to even more
of these issues jordan by serving on
that commission and we've
put out a report to congress
called transportation for tomorrow i'm
i'm kind of laughing because it was put
out in 2008 just as the global financial
system was melting down and we we didn't
ever got the attention that we hope but
we did have some impact but jordan i
came to realize the importance of these
issues and how in some sense
understudied they were and in particular
by economics departments right back in
my day in college almost every economics
department had a transportation
economist and that slowly went by the
wayside and the transportation policy
issues
really were not being studied
how come it went by the wayside i mean
in canada it was infrastructure that
delivered this country it was a railroad
that tied us together so infrastructure
actually is at the basis of our country
and when i go down to the states and i
see that
that interstate highway system that was
built between the 50s and the 90s that
bloody thing's a miracle and it's an
economic miracle as well i don't think
it could be built today maybe i'm
cynical about that but it could not
okay why do you say that why could not
it not be built today given how crucial
that piece of infrastructure is because
so one of the issues that that we study
um one of the things that that i became
um interested in we actually just put
out a working paper a couple days ago
through my cpip program here at cornell
is called nepa and that's the national
environmental policy act of 1970
which is a
broad act
where you have to file an environmental
impact statement an eis in order to
design and construct a new facility
expand an old facility do almost
anything
and part of the reason why i say that
jordan is because the nepa process
has become much much larger to the point
where it can slow down projects
routinely for a decade right i think the
average might be five we have in our
research paper so let me push you on
that and maybe greg can jump in here too
so now the biden administration has
decided to make
infrastructure renovation and renewal
yes one of its primary focuses and we
were greg and i were both talking to a
republican congressman a while back and
asked him what impediments he might see
to its implementation and he raised the
same issue that you just described which
is that the the red tape surrounding
infrastructure renewal is now so dense
that it's not obvious what can actually
be done and so this actually puts the
people say on the center left in
somewhat of a conundrum because on the
one hand they want to build
infrastructure
not least to serve the interests of the
poor and the working class absolutely
because because the rich can't take
infrastructure for themselves let's say
but if it's if the regulatory structure
is such that these projects are actually
not practically implementable
well
is that is that a reasonable credit
criticism that you're levying now is it
reasonable to place you politically on
the on the moderate right let's say and
does that and how does that influence
your thinking about such things
i i mean jordan i come from a classical
liberal libertarian scottish
enlightenment um neo-classical economics
i have my doctor from chicago right um
in in in sort of the hot uh one one of
the uh golden ears i would say of of
chicago economics
uh i guess you could place me you know
wherever uh you want given given that
information
um
but yeah i take a basic market oriented
approach i mean i i wrote a book on
increased private uh participation uh in
in the delivery of public services which
is a huge issue globally right how the
private sector that has capital that has
technology that has management expertise
that has experience around the world can
help to deliver public what are
fundamentally uh public goods and
services so i think it's it's fair to
put me slightly you know affiliated with
american enterprise slightly to the
right
of the center on this but i do want to
go you know go back to this drawing
because i i think it's it's a really
interesting point that people should be
aware of so you've heard the adage that
time is money right time is money that
is really true in infrastructure if you
delay a project by five or seven years
uh because of the the
nepa process right then then you just
increase the cost enormously i mean it
could double the cost or some something
of that of that nature
and so what's happening now
it's actually very interesting i think
you'll find this very interesting during
the trump administration uh there were
folks in the white house who who
suggested a new model for nepa and it's
called the one federal decision right
one federal decision and that is the
idea that you would have a lead federal
agency
so you wouldn't have the environmental
protection agency and you'd have uh
native american burial grounds and you
might have some other uh all these
different agencies that have to weigh in
for project approval one agency would
take the lead in shepherding
the enviro the the
proposal right through the federal
process and they would they that agency
could actually if the other agencies
were dragging their feet would have the
power basically to make a decision for
them the the situation now jordan is one
agency will head it off hand the uh
proposal off to another and that'll hand
it off to another and off to another and
as you can see it slows down the process
uh enormously and i believe that in the
bill that was signed by or voted on by
the house late on friday night the one
federal decision language is in the bill
right but on the other hand
uh there's um folks within the uh biden
administration who are trying to walk
back some of the trump era
reforms with regard to expediting the
environmental impact statement process
right so i think we all want to protect
the environment we all want to protect
endangered species we want to protect
the water the air native american burial
grounds you know and so on but there has
to be some limit on how much time can be
uh spent you know on these things before
you either say yes or no
basically so there's a bit of
polls things are being pulled in two
different directions with the the bill
basically saying
we're going to do one federal decision
and that's going to be a big reform of
the nepa process that policy people like
me love and then there's another poll
within the administration to kind of
repeal some of the trump era reforms on
this
so one of the big things we would like
to see is some
sys it hasn't really been reformed since
which is a long time ago and there's as
you know jordan an ecosystem of
lawyers and consultants etc in
washington that have built up around the
nepa process
and they they you know that whole thing
slows it down
so so that would be one sort of major
uh reform that we think would expedite
infrastructure delivery in the united
states uh you know speed it up and
essentially do it at lower cost
and so um
you know we're hopeful that that's when
the president signs the bill that
that'll be you know part of it and we'll
see some changes but in answer to your
original question jordan things i think
are so
cumbersome at this stage that you could
never build the interstate highway
system in the united states today the
way you did in the 50s and 60s yeah so
the chinese announced 150 nuclear plants
today i think today or yesterday wow
yeah that's that's their plan and so
greg you had a question
well i was thinking you know one of the
things jordan and i talk about sometimes
is the aim that we strive for in our in
our mutual work is to try and get people
arguing and talking about the right
things at least right versus how so much
conversation goes and i was really
struck by even something that's as as
seemingly uncontroversial as
infrastructure
there's very little discussion in in
the media
in conversations around this topic with
any sophistication like even something
like infrastructure to me has been
pushed into such
sort of gridlock that any discussion of
regulation from the left is viewed as
you know corporations trying to roll
back stuff so they can dump toxins into
oceans and make more profit rather than
that being able to be framed and
described as you're doing it everybody
has an intuitive sense of that anyone
who's ever done a remodel or had a home
project everyone knows the cost and the
expense of anything that takes longer
and how onerous that is and how many
different layers
and you know part of what the from the
messaging perspective
is how do we you know yet again it's
another example about how the working
class small businesses and the poor are
being held hostage by
a messaging uh apparatus from both sides
that has sort of distilled the argument
into
sort of tribal warfare on either side it
seems like we can get very little same
discussion in mainstream media
about the role for instance that
regulation plays and how to strike the
balance and you're so clear about it you
know of course we need to you know
protect the environment of course we
care about you know
species and extinction and disruptions
to the habitat but we also can't take
six years to build an overpass in new
york city it's just not going to be
functional not not and remain not in re
retain an economy that simultaneously
serves the needs of the people who are
released well off
because they're the ones who will pay
the price for those delays fundamentally
absolutely another way of saying that
jordan is all these delays and uh cost
it's
it's like a regressive tax right
in other words right it's a tax
economist would think about it as an
implicit tax that disproportionately
hurts the poor
you know okay why did this result
why disproportionately hurts the poor
well i mean these the these uh
facilities you know let's go back and
and and talk about the actual facilities
you know the the actual infrastructure
right that we're talking about as i
stress it provides basic public goods
and services so mobility getting getting
to to school getting to your work you
know getting to your community
activities right the the the history of
infrastructures and this goes 200 years
back in the u.s postal service
is the history of trying to provide all
communities
with access right or being sure that no
communities are left out
that goes back to the horse post right
when you were delivering letters and
cards and newspapers by horse
and the goal in the united states was
that all communities should have access
to a post office right and and the
history of uh infrastructure in the
united states universal landline
telephones there was a farms to markets
uh movement where we tried to pave rural
roads
because farmers couldn't get their their
harvest to the market you know in time
on dirt roads that were full of mud so
there was this this farms to markets
there was electrification during the
roosevelt year rural electrification so
there's always this this and we see it
now with broadband right now is
broadband
access consistently in our polling we go
out often into the
37 congressional districts decided by
five points we really want to see what
people think to cut through it and
consistently rural broadband tests
through the roof as a necessity right it
is the new those are the new information
highways right it's the new it is the
new infrastructure system and we see a
huge demand need for that
well and think of all the educational
opportunities that provides as well and
increasingly so and so okay so let me
ask you another kind of technical
question
please go ahead the whole was universal
access and that's includes
the the
the poorest communities right rural
communities poor urban communities it's
always been across sectors this goal of
everybody having access and that's
fundamentally what the infrastructure is
about
okay so do you think so here's a
proposition twofold proposition
the most important thing that might be
done to rectify absolute poverty and
maybe to mitigate relative poverty would
be the provision of energy as cheaply as
possible and the second most important
would be the universal provision of
efficient infrastructure is that a
reasonable prop are those propositions
reasonable from the perspective of an
economist yes absolutely absolutely
crucial but i would i would say that the
energy infrastructure the energy is part
of the infrastructure the generating
distribution and transmission capacity
you need to get power right to people
that that's a crucial we kind of the you
know the
extension of that is uh we don't like to
live in a society where some communities
are
systematically don't have these things
right we kind of think everybody should
have heat everybody should have electric
everybody should have mobility right in
in your community so i would say
absolutely you know and that's that's
why having these things there's this big
notion of equity right which is kind of
kind of this this amorphous term and
some of us are bothered by
the lack of definition but in
infrastructure it is used generally i
think it's this old notion of universal
service universal access
where all it's it's equitable for all
communities to have this and of course
i'm a consider myself to be an old-time
regulatory economist and i'm always
harping on how these
issues have been studied for a century
or longer in the you know to provide
these basic services as the technology
evolves and now of course with this zoom
call we know how important broadband
internet access is
and kids need to have it for school and
people need to have it for work and so
we don't want either urban pockets to be
left without it you know or or rural so
jordan i don't know if i'm answering
your question but but there's a certain
level of power that we need
well the other thing that that i've
thought a lot about is pareto
distribution problems and so you know
the fact that money for example does
tend to end up in the hands of fewer and
fewer people you have to fight very hard
to not have that happen but that doesn't
seem to me to be the case with
infrastructure because well it can't
happen that way you can't hoard the
highways you can't hoard the electrical
grid and even if you did it wouldn't do
you any good
and so
if you are okay if you are actually
devoted to serving
those who are oppressed and excluded at
the bottom of the socioeconomic and
power hierarchies then i can't think of
a way to facilitate equitable
distribution of valuable resources
especially energy because energy is work
i can't think of a better way of doing
that than to concentrate on
infrastructure development and so then
that brings us to the next problem
that's going to be a big one for this
infrastructure bill is like
as pressure ramps up in relationship to
climate change and the environmental
concerns that go along with that there's
going to be more and more pressure on
infrastructure development like to in
terms of regulating and suppressing it
for that matter and so that that's a
real tension on the left i think because
the left tends to be more concerned
let's say with broad scale environmental
issues but theoretically also they're
concerned with the poor and there's a
big tension there and so do you have
some sense of how those mutual
goals might be brought into alignment
with one another instead of acting in an
antagonistic manner so jordan i i think
you've hit on one of the most important
and under-appreciated issues in
infrastructure
uh policy and i kind of regret that i
didn't spend more time in my book
that you have on this but i've been
studying this for for 15 years
now and i would say there's been a slow
revolution going on in the technology of
infrastructure delivery right and some
of those things make you know the the
front page of the new york times and
that's driverless cars right and the
hyperloop and things like that but
there's a whole host of other
technologies
that have been developed in the
universities in the labs and the
startups that that stand to transform
the way infrastructure delivery
infrastructure is is operated and
delivered in the united states let me
give you a couple examples one is smart
stop lights okay smart stop lights i had
a
uh uh kind of a little briefing of this
by the folks at carnegie mellon recently
and it's a it's a stop light right with
different colors but it has a camera and
a sensor attached to it so that the
lights are not just on a rope timer they
actually change in response to the
traffic that's actually at the
intersection so many drivers have had
the experience of going to a royal road
and there's a red light and because
they're good people they stop and wait
there and there's no traffic in the
other direction and they just know that
if the light knew that i was sitting
there it would turn green what turns out
the technology has existed for a decade
to sense the cars actually at the
intersection and change the lights
optimally
in response to the traffic at the
intersection jordan they have it now to
the point where they can sense
pedestrians and include pedestrians in
the changing of the light they have it
to dog they can tell a dog they can tell
a person in a wheelchair and they can
just change the the optimize the
changing of the colors to maximize the
flow through the intersection now stop
and think for a minute how much gasoline
you would save if you did that how much
fuel how much frustration how much time
how much patience we just had smart stop
lights now there's something in the bill
that's a pilot program to help
with that right but the problem jordan
is not the technology the problem is the
adoption right is getting the people who
own the stoplights you might be a small
town like where i am in ithaca or it
could be you know a county it could be a
city but it's highly atomized in the
united states but but getting them to to
overcome their risk aversion and i
understand that totally they're
risk-averse to new technologies they're
afraid of it they don't what we call
headline risk you're the mayor and
you're afraid you're going to wake up
tomorrow and find that there's been a
giant crash because these stop lights
malfunctioned right but we've got to
somehow overcome that risk aversion to
get them to adopt these new technologies
okay so well so one of the things you're
saying is that part of the
infrastructure messaging and and i don't
mean messaging in the cynical way you
know because i would hope that the
messaging is actually associated with
the underlying policies so it's a
straight game but
if infrastructure development means
replacing inefficient use of resources
with efficient use of resources that
should be a net gain on the economic
side so for poor people plus it should
have environmental benefits so yes we
shouldn't be thinking about it exactly
okay okay okay okay so so
how about priorities like you you give
the highway systems in this book for
example in the us i think it's a d and
the bridge is a c minus and then that's
american society of civil engineers
right so if if you were going to rank
order infrastructure priorities in the
united states i know that's a big task
but you've thought about this for a long
time like what's really broken what
really where's the and where's the
biggest bang for the buck
so so george yeah let me uh wow that is
a is a great question
you know
the american society of civil engineers
has done a great job of pointing to the
inadequate the deferred maintenance
right
in the united states so so the bottom
line is i think the us has done a good
job
of designing and constructing and
building out new networks to ensure that
all communities are connected right the
interstate highway system the state
routes
the local streets you know in
infrastructure same thing across
you know across sectors but we've done a
very so we're good at building shiny new
things
but we're very poor at taking care of
what we have already and i think there's
political incentives right if you want
to be re-elected you want the
ribbon-cutting ceremony with the big
scissors
right but it doesn't get you reelected
if you say we put five millimeters of
asphalt on that bridge over there even
though the civil engineers are telling
you you need to resurface that bridge
so there's a problem with uh the
political incentives that have led to
these trillions of dollars you know of
deferred maintenance and i think in in
the build so of course
that's part of the debt that's part of
the debt that differed maintenance even
that's also part of this part that's
also part of messaging failure you know
as you're describing the stop lights and
that's like the send city stuff right
you can plug in car like the the stop
lights also have
so many other aspects as charging
stations and different security they can
alert to gun shots like there's so much
in it that's efficient
um and to me i just hear that as a you
know obviously
being somebody who's more
involved with the messaging side of it
but that seems to me to get somewhere
like ithaca to adopt that it has to be
framed as an environmental imperative
like you want to cut gasoline costs
here's how we do it here's how the city
is cleaner here's where the money will
scoot other people there's a way that
that has to be packaged and sold that's
outside of the norm right i think the
thing that we see increasingly is that
we we you know the way that the
information
the way that information moves now and
polarizes and is sold we expect
politicians to also have to figure out
how to be tick-tock stars that they know
exactly how to sell everything in some
magical fashion and the lack of a proper
messaging apparatus around some of this
stuff um is is really costly and people
tend to forget that that's just as
essential as figuring out the problems
if you can't sell them and communicate
to people in real concrete terms the
ways it will affect their lives in their
communities it doesn't get adopted
yeah right so that's also an
infrastructure problem in some sense
right and and no no no non-trivial one
at that
so how do you make these things sexy i
mean i made a joke about that at the
beginning
uh you know that these these tend to be
regarded as dry discussions but they're
not they're they're the real details of
actual policy the real details of actual
politics and what we're laying out here
at the moment is a vision that's
something like
well how does enhanced efficiency like
why is that a problem for anyone well
it's more efficient go ahead no we're
real quick also this is where
ideologies and by that i i don't just
mean far left and far right i also mean
like classically conservative and
classically liberal this is where they
come to die in in a good way in the
solution of a problem like if we can
have this conversation about
specifically how this makes people's
lives better
maybe that's a solution that's 70
conservative 30 liberal when it comes to
some application maybe
and so what's so important about boiling
them down to this and figuring how to
talk about it is a lot of the useless
ideological overlay to specific problems
that concretely help the working class
and the poor and actually make headway
for community
uh environment and that's also you know
clean fields and streams right we're not
just talking global warming we're
talking about literal the communities
that people live in that they fish in
that small businesses are run in
um you know that's where all the rubber
meets the road and then greg it might be
a it might be a rule of thumb that if
the discussion is occurring at a level
where all that's happening is
ideological argument then the problem
actually hasn't been specified clearly
enough to move towards solution right it
might be a good feeling well then you
also see in your way right is it
bureaucrats is it businesses that are
legitimately looking to
override regulation for for ill
motivation if we could if once it gets
boiled down it also you get a very clear
lay of what the strategic field looks
like for pushing something through
so jordan i i want to
address um your your just a few minutes
ago you said who who could be against uh
greater efficiency
right and i think this this in some
sense the greats point should be the
ultimate bipartisan
issue right i'm not sure
with all due respect i'm not sure
engineers are the greatest on the
messaging uh piece of this um i love him
to death
but but there is this issue so let me
give you two other examples i want to
get off my chest
and you know uh you know there ain't
saying there ain't no such thing as a
free lunch but the closest thing to a
free lunch in economics is technological
adoption right so one great example i
think is completely underappreciated
i you know we're all concerned about
climate change and it's methane
emissions at wastewater treatment plants
right so a lot of wastewater treatment
plants particularly in the eastern
united states are old ours here in
ithaca was over 100 years old
and they're open settling ponds for
solid waste well guess what happens the
methane from that process just goes into
the atmosphere which is a very bad
greenhouse gas
so what you can do and what the city of
ithaca did where we are the the mayor is
a cornell graduate was partner with a
private company in this case it's
johnson controls to install a digester
and i've had the tour the digester looks
like a giant tennis ball it's a big
white sphere with a plunger they capture
the methane from the natural process of
of breaking down the solids they use the
methane to turn turbines that johnson
control installed three of them at 120
000 rpms they're very very
efficient they make electricity they
capture the methane so it doesn't go
into the atmosphere it doesn't cause
climate change they instead use that to
create electricity so they offset other
generating sources now our wastewater
treatment plant sells power to the grid
instead of using power from the grid to
run the plant they sell power to the
grid it's a win-win-win right
to the point where they're gonna since i
believe they're gonna install another
digester and they're actually taking
waste from other surrounding communities
to process here right they charge
something called a tipping fee right
they don't the city doesn't do that for
free they do that for a charge and so
this
this should be done on at scale in the
united states where where
you know this is where you have to have
a private sector company because it's
it's technologically challenging to
install this and install the generating
capacities micro
generators to get them to work properly
but now we have you know taken a 100
year plan
with private sector oh the other thing i
should say is how do you pay for this
right if you're the mayor the first
everybody's cash strap so guess what
johnson controls was able to pay for the
installation of the digester by getting
a share of the lowered electric bill so
think about that they knew that our
wastewater treatment electric bill was
going to go down they said just give us
a share of the electric bill we will
bond against that savings and we'll pay
for the installation of the technology
well you've just got the mayor's ear
right so so i don't understand why we
can't replicate that across
the united states there should be no
open
wastewater treatment settling ponds that
are 100 years old emitting methane that
could be used to power the plant and
power the city so this this i don't know
if it's a messaging or a
or i don't know what it is well who's
really good at messaging or corporations
right they're really good at it you can
turn on the tv look at what exxonmobil
does right
and so it's really interesting because
in a certain way as you lay it out if if
there's a for-profit
aspect to this from private industry
that benefit cities at no cost to get
something in place that also earns
cities money it seems to me like that's
a perfect
union for private and public interface
and so
somebody it seems to me like the the
most immediate driver for that would be
for the private corporation to figure
out how to package and sell that to
other cities that's a bigger driver to
me i think than trying to convince
layers of bureaucracy and governments
why this makes sense and to adopt it
through you know city boards or councils
or however that works well i would
presume that's also partly why in your
book this road to renewal that you also
stress the utility of public private
uh joint ventures and so maybe we could
go into that okay so here's a couple of
things we've sketched out is
well let's go for efficiency because
that's going to serve us on the
environmental front but it's also going
to be economically efficient and then we
could also point out that there's a big
argument always going on
ideologically in some sense between
malthusian biologists and enthusiastic
economists and the malthusian biologists
insist whether limits to growth
everything has a maximal carrying
capacity we can't exceed that and and
there are malthusian catastrophes but
the economists come in and say yeah well
wait a minute one of the ways that we
can solve that is by doing more with
less and we're really good at that and
we're getting faster and faster at being
better and better at it and i think the
economists to my way of thinking the
economists are the optimists and i think
they have the upper hand in the argument
but this is a perfect
marriage of those two things in some
sense because it means that the optimal
infrastructure plans please both sides
it's like yeah this this is going to be
better for the environment plus it will
make poor people people wealthier right
so how is that not exactly what we
should be aiming for and then well the
messaging issue well that's a pretty
easy message to sell especially if it's
true and so
let and so let's go into the public
private issue a bit can i give can i get
i want to give you guys a third example
before we go to the public private
just attack because this jordan gets
directly to the point you just made
right
i emphasized stop lights before now i'm
going to emphasize street lights right
on parking lots you have the for
roads where you have the street you know
to illuminate the thing at night
the the thing now that's the methane
capture equivalent for street lights we
talked about stop lights is led
conversions so so if you if you fly over
a parking lot in your plane at night you
see this yellowish color
from the bulbs this old pressurized so
sodium incandescent
technology is very old
leds
and street lights are so much more
efficient
that you can again
you can install the bulbs you can
install the the new towers and you can
do it at virtually no cost to the city
by the savings on the electric bill but
they're so much more efficient that you
get you get more lumens right you get
more brightness
and this was done in the city of detroit
i believe that paris
did this but think about the effects of
that right you have more brightness that
reduces crime that reduces pedestrian
accidents that reduces car accidents at
night this this helps communities at at
almost no cost to the jurisdiction that
is installing them and you can do other
things like you can hang 5g what they
call pizza boxes which are 5g
transmitters on those towers and you
start to deliver higher speed internet
at the same time you're improving the uh
the lighting so so there's there's all
these innovations that are completely
underappreciated in this debate and i
have to say i'm somewhat frustrated that
there's not more focus on these
opportunities so that in fact i think
the street lights is what i was thinking
about for the charging of cars and other
things rather than the stop lights which
was your earlier example but a quick
question for you while we're on
specifics which is this you said that
it's it's johnson industries
controls johnson
i mean it shows
i mean so clearly they have an outreach
business development office like what do
you think the impediments are to them
going and pitching this and just having
explosive growth if in fact all of these
things line out you've assessed them i'm
just i'm just curious like why they
can't move from that from city to town
to city to town
i think they can i mean um
it's a that's a really interesting
question greg
the the case in ithaca i'm pretty sure
is what we call an unsolicited proposal
right so it's not like the city of
ithaca came and say hey we want somebody
to do methane capture on our wastewater
treatment plant i'm pretty sure johnson
controls studied the situation and
approached the city
and said you guys should do this right
one thing again is you know it's the
united states and it's this this frankly
balkanized system of of delivery and
many in many sectors and they're they're
a bit jealous of they want local control
right and they're a bit afraid i think
they're so small a lot of these
wastewater treatment systems are small
they're afraid of a big company
right so it has it has to be done
properly i don't really have a good
answer to your to your question greg but
i think smart public policy and this
gets to jordan's point about public
private cooperation how can we do that
better right smart public
would encourage this encourage this okay
well some of it is a matter of
decreasing distrust you know i mean for
a public-private partnership to work the
private sector has to trust the public
sector and the public sector has to
trust the private sector and then for
that to be marketable to the population
at large people have to believe that the
institutions are fundamentally sound and
that would mean the governmental
institutions which the left tends to
take for granted as being sound not
always
uh it depends on who's who's in power
but also the private
institutions which the right tend to
take for granted as as sound but
there isn't any reason that we couldn't
reconfigure our beliefs at least to some
degree and think well look we could all
we could unite in the pursuit of of
efficiency and environmental cleanliness
right it's like what where the hell's
the problem with that and one of the
things that's quite disturbing to me
when i look at the united states is
when i travel from canada to the united
states i'm always happy to be in the
states i go to new york city and i look
at i was in manhattan this week and i
think this bloody place is it's such a
miracle
like there's seven million people there
crammed onto this island
and it's clean
like it's actually clean how do you do
this this is impossible it's such a
bloody miracle and then wonderful i see
the country like rivening it itself
apart and tearing itself apart with his
ideological struggles and not noticing
that it's really pretty damn good and
your institutions work remarkably well
and like what's all the paranoia about
folks and well those are discussions
that greg and i have had on on other
issues and
so this issue of trust greg seems to me
to be central to this in part is like
and also the the provision of something
like an optimistic vision which would be
well we don't have to it's not limits to
growth it's not it's not the rome club
in 1968 saying we're going to be
overpopulated by the year 2000 and we've
got to shut all this down it's like no
we can solve the environmental problem
and we can solve the economic problem
and if we do them properly we're going
to solve both better and faster yes and
i think that's actually realistic
yes it's happening in certain cases i
mean i'm giving you examples of where
all these technologies
are being it's not a there's no silver
bullet it's it's not this is the real
world but it's it's a win-win-win and it
needs to happen let me say something
jordan and greg i just love your
reactions so i've been studying the
infrastructure delivery around the world
and i'm pretty sure that in developed
countries and many developing countries
the united states is dead last in
public-private cooperation if you go to
france they have an office of
partnerships the french word for that in
paris
that that automatically assumes that the
public and private sector will come
together to deliver the infrastructure
jordan the way the canals in in france
were delivered in the 17th century was
through a pub that was the way you moved
freight back then was through a
public-private partnership it was
through a concession if you go to canada
where you are canada is one of the
world's leaders in public private
partnership you guys have these what are
called pvp units
for ontario has one uh quebec has one
you know i could just go on and then
there's a national one and it's all to
facilitate public private cooperation i
spent a year on sabbatical in australia
uh as a fulbright scholar to study their
infrastructure delivery every state in
australia new south wales uh
queensland you know go on they all have
an office of a ppp unit or an office of
partnerships and then they have a
federal one that's called infrastructure
australia to facilitate public private
cooperation
and the united states the two sides are
just completely suspicious of each other
but we're supposed to be capitalists do
you think that's because the the the
general and generally speaking that
liberals have distrust of private
business and conservatives have distrust
of government i mean do you think those
are the drivers of why
yeah so greg it's that's a really good
question i think there's probably a
book
that but here's here's my quick answer
so the united states you have to go go
then to the financing of infrastructure
this it sounds opaque but this is one of
the most i think important issues
and i'll get to the details the united
states i've talked to people around the
world
is the only country i'm aware of that
has this tax treatment of a publicly
issued debt
all right so that's tax exempt municipal
bonds right so what that means is if
you're the bond holder you buy the bonds
you do not pay federal tax on the income
okay now think of what that does so if
you're the issuer say you're the city of
ithaca and you're the mayor and you
issue bonds to pay for a new um bridge
and you have to issue 10 100 million
dollars of bonds
you get a lower interest rate because
their tax exempt municipal bonds right
so this pushes infrastructure delivery
in the united states away from
public-private partnerships right and
this is now a multi-trillion dollar
market that pushes it away from
public-private partnerships and towards
public sector only uh delivery
do you think there's any possibility
that that could be modified or is that
an impossible task so jordan that's that
is a
multi-trillion dollar financial market
on wall street now um the the political
forces that are going to protect
you know are going to protect that uh
tax exemption are very strong but it's
in the bill jordan what they have the tr
the people
in washington have recognized this
problem we call it an unlevel cost of
capital playing field where the tax
treatment artificially lowers
hold on a second sorry the the tax
treatment artificially lowers the cost
of capital meaning the cost of money
right if it's if it's a tax exam
municipal
bond that's not issued by a private
company right so in the bill they have
something called private activity bonds
or pads and what that does is it extends
that that tax exemption to pub to
privately issued debt through a ppp
now now i could go into the details what
did you call that what was it was
private private activity bond
hab
private activity bonds please do not
confuse it with a bab
which is a build america bond it's
different the the the real the real
action is in the pads the private
activity bonds the united states
treasury is jealous of the fisk of the
public fisk right and so they don't like
to give tax exemptions so the the old
law was 15 billion dollar cap right the
total amount of issuance of tabs with 15
billion jordan the new bill would double
it to 30.
so so people like us say that's great
it's not enough but the 50 they hit the
15 billion dollar cap the pabs were so
popular at least the bill doubles it
right and we would like to see it it's
only for transportation i think we would
like to see pebbs the cap on pads
increased and also be use it for other
things like water
or
power whatever the you know those things
are but economists do not like to see
economic decisions distorted by tax law
right and i'm getting to craig's point i
think i think
the united states is kind of behind this
because it's so easy to just use taxes
on municipal bonds if you're a public
owner of infrastructure and to say the
heck with the pvp right you guys are
going to have taxable debt that's going
to cost me more
i'm just going to go with taxis at muni
debt and so it's it's this odd
thing that has caused you know
supposedly free enterprise
america to be kind of adverse to private
cooperation and infrastructure delivery
is that why you think that
it's almost like the larger forces the
foundational forces
are skewed from this tax perspective and
so for something to break through it's
got to be wildly innovative
and
um immediately profit driven like the
example with johnson and the methane
right it has to be something that's so
innovative and so tip of the arrow that
it can offer a solution that doesn't
rely on the bigger sort of capital raise
with the tax ramifications and so if
there's stuff that's in between if
there's stuff that requires a bigger
investment of capital upfront it seems
like that's where it will get caught
versus a situation like that where a
private company can come in hard in
exchange for a for a forever share of a
percentage of profit
which makes it worthwhile
no i i think i think that's right greg
and i'm not i want to be clear i'm not
faulting the the public owners uh you
know
the mayors i think it's mostly the
mayors it could be count executives or
governors but really it seems like the
mayors are the people who are dealing uh
with most of this and i've heard stories
greg
where where they'll be they'll they have
to do a new project right they have to
finance it they will have two groups
coming from the same bank
from the same bank the one group is
pushing taxes and municipal bonds and
the other group is pushing
public-private partnerships
and the mayor just says look my interest
payments my service on the debt is going
to be a lot lower with the taxes and
municipal bond group so i'm going to do
that you know and it's almost like a
fiscal
okay so why is that okay why is that bad
though let's go into that because if
he's saving money doing that and and the
project is going to go ahead anyways
then why not take that route what's the
cost of not rectifying this
so jordan the cost is a crowds out
private participation
because the private folks cannot compete
a lot of these things are levered you
know it's 80 percent that 20 percent
equity and they can't they just cannot
compete with this
artificially low cost of capital
communities but okay and so what's the
problem what's the problem with leaving
okay so what's the problem with just
leaving it in the hands of the of the
government
now we talked about messaging right
so what's the problem there exactly so
jordan you don't get the innovation you
you don't get you don't get the
risk-bearing benefits of including the
private partners
one day they're good at risk management
you do not get the new technologies the
other thing i i should have harped on
more in that book is what's called the
the life cycle asset maintenance
and that means if you do a ppp you wrap
the design and construction in with the
operation over maybe 25 or 30 years so
that means the contract requires the
public owner to keep the infrastructure
up
right and this is one of the things that
i heart the united states last time i
checked is a relatively wealthy country
why is our infrastructure degraded it's
because we haven't done the operation
and maintenance over the life of the
facility the way the civil engineers
told you to
so so it's called a dbos so the
incentives are wrong i mean that what
that means is fundamentally these
incentives are wrong right so screwed up
yeah they're all screwed up i mean and i
i have
said in every venue i can to do to wrap
those things together a bundle that the
term is to bundle design and
construction that could be renovation
but bundle it in with o m with operation
and maintenance and the poor bless their
hearts the port authority of new york
and new jersey you mentioned new york
have the authority to do this on their
own the new gothels bridge i've had a
tour it's a hundred year bridge it's
built to last a hundred years beautiful
bridge is a d-bomb it's a design build
operate maintain contract
over 25 or 30 years i forget the exact
and there's other there's other
facilities i think maybe it's the new
laguardia terminal is a d-bomb contract
so jordan what answer your question that
i think the tax community debt was very
good for the united states in
in this developmental stage but now it's
it's become a
you know a problem
right an albatross in some sense because
it crowds out these
uh private
partnerships that the rest of the world
canada is the leader you know the rest
of the world has been using in spades
in terms of messaging one of the things
you did in your book is you pointed to a
lot of projects that were really
radically successful and so i'm kind of
imagining a messaging campaign where
you know there's some focus like an ad a
focus on a project that really worked
and some discussion of why this worked
and what work means you know it's more
efficient it's cheaper it's better for
the environment everybody wins that's
pretty good
and and then and then to scaffold that
up
upward
to include larger and larger projects
that have exactly the same sort of aim
it would be something like that but so
would it be possible because this book's
somewhat old can you think of a number
of projects you talked about the methane
capture system
are there projects that could be
profitably assessed that have been
radically successful that work on all
fronts that would be that could be used
as detailed templates for messaging
going forward with infrastructure
development would that be a good
approach because it kind of ties the
high to the low right
absolutely so
yes i mean so one of the things um i
have research you you might appreciate
in nature i'm very proud of that because
of the general interest readership of
nature and science right with two great
great people peter crampton who actually
uh his father was was dean of the law
school here he grew up in ithaca and
axel oakenfeld's and axel's at the
university of cologne and the nature
paper lays down how
road pricing right pricing the use of
the road which a pilot project is in the
bill that was just signed by the house
of representatives could help to
alleviate and in fact eliminate traffic
congestion but people don't talk oh my
god what would we do without traffic
congestion
yeah well people spend like an hour a
day people's people spend like a half
time job in traffic congestion this is
not a trivial problem
it's unbelievably economic drain and
it's terribly polluting but jordan look
look at what what do they do what's the
first thing that you hear when people
say this road is congested they say
build another lane build build another
highway right and there's economic
research that shows it's what called
induced demand it is the the fact that
you have added a lane
adds to the demand on the highway the
developer says oh there's a new
interstate highway here i'm going to put
a housing development in well what does
that do to the interstate highway it
adds to congestion
and so so they're always looking for
these capacity expansions or they're
looking for new and wild technologies
right i love the hyperloop you know
they're saying let's do a hyperloop but
the economics 101 jordan the first
semester of microeconomics provides the
answer where the problem is that the
price of the road space is zero right
it's a free good so it's just like if
you have a pile of free bananas and a
pile of price bananas at the grocery
store people are going to take the free
bananas and they're going to be gone
right and so so it's an artificial free
too because it's not free because people
are paying for it with their time and
it's the old soviet system it's queuing
yeah
with a lot of these problems
systemically i'm just trying to think
through how this works you know with
people making decisions i'm not as
familiar with with you know
mayor offices though i'm though i'm
somewhat but i mean so there's a couple
things we're back to the age-old problem
of term limits right because if you're
making a choice on which
tax which is going to be more tax
efficient for your
two years four years for whatever your
term is it's going to make sense in the
short term but not in the long term and
so
to overcome that
people mayors have to be armed with a
whole different story that they're able
to tell and market and draw voters with
because under current circumstances and
you know the other thing that i think
about that i don't think any one of us
is going to have an answer
to immediately but i just thought i
would raise it that we're seeing
everywhere i'm sure you see it in all of
your ventures is
people are so busy scrambling
to keep up with
i'm going to call it corruption and by
that i don't mean overt corruption i
mean all the nonsense and clogging that
goes into
the act of being let's say a politician
right the amount of just chasing can get
right the congestion
that there is no time to consider and to
weigh things out in a way that involves
bigger picture innovative thinking so
the easiest thing is to just pull the
lever on what you've been doing all
along right right and i'm seeing that a
lot what you're saying to adopt new
technology to sell it somebody has to
really understand that they have to go
into it like the methane capture they
have to go into private business they
have to figure out what regulations need
to be cleared to figure out how to
package that and sell that and no one's
doing congress
and when congressmen are spending 25
hours a week
uh fundraising because they have to how
the hell are they going to take the time
to dig into something at this level of
detail and that's that's more like
congestion than corruption really
right it's easy it's easy to be cynical
about that but it's not helpful but also
nobody gets fired if you pull a lever on
something everyone's been doing for 50
years 75 years where you get hired is if
you have and you advocate for that
partnership and it turns into a disaster
and so there's a lot of ways that people
are are risk averse based on the system
and i think you know for me
i hate to sound like you know a hammer
where everything's a nail but you know
the only contribution really that i can
offer that's significant is on the
storytelling front which is yeah
messaging which for me messaging is
distinct from propaganda if you can get
the messaging right sometimes you can
get the policy right
yeah but craig let me let me uh you know
expand that a little bit
and this gets to jordan's point
these are great you know great people
it's been wonderful for me to interact
with the people actually own and operate
and have responsibility for
infrastructure right
um
why why why why has that been wonderful
because because they they they really
care about the public services right
they're really trying to provide clean
water they're really trying to you know
make make the
the roads work they're they're you know
and a mayor you know has got 50 you know
15 different things
every day
you know that's a problem whether it's
interacting with the police or the
potholes or
you know
in ethics dealing with cornell you know
and i i really do think that that they
try
their best you know it's a hard job i
mean to be the person who is in charge
of this by the way the u.s interstate
highway system
zero
of it is owned by the federal government
it's entirely owned by a state states
and that means if you're a governor you
have the responsibility for operating it
maintaining it policing it
taking care of the dead animals
resurfacing it taking care of the the
signage and the line pain i mean it's a
it's a big job and i think a lot
particularly and it's not glamorous
it's not commerce
but greg nobody wants to go first nobody
wants to go first you don't want to be
the mayor of charleston and you install
the the smart stop lights and then
everything screws up right
so you this is why i think pilot
projects you know whatever the
technology is
pilots
so
geeks like me and other academics can
study the pilots right about them
produce you know reports and saying this
is what did well this is what did poorly
this is what you the mayor of syracuse
you know or wherever you are should do
but that but there's really this risk
aversion while in these pilot projects
then partly what the engineers and the
economists
should be thinking about too is is not
only you know do these work and what are
the outcomes economically but is there a
way of constructing an incentive system
around the successful project so that
the people who took the risk are
rewarded for having taken the risk and
so that that becomes part of their
political capital because without that
being solved solving the other problems
is going to be sufficient because
they're just punished for mistakes
they're not rewarded for movement
forward it's it's so true so true
not to keep harping on methane capture
but it's such a compelling and concrete
thing i mean part of how i would think
if if
for johnson if they're going to target
that is to
do a breakdown and say here's how much
money
the city made here's how much time they
saved here's how much right revenue is
generated here's their cost basis i mean
all these things can be broken down and
handed off in a way that's a neat
package of like we can make an
investment here's how much money that
you'll make in an ongoing way and here's
a small slice of it that's a reasonable
reward for a company who's taking the
the expense up front yeah so greg let me
let me say um one thing about that
let me get get back to the uh screen
here
um
this is an interesting uh left of center
right of center thing uh you know in
some cases right
uh for infrastructure to improve
infrastructure delivery we cannot avoid
the p word and the p word is
privatization right
and so i have because of who i am i'm
not in a company or anything
some of these infrastructure companies
are happy to talk to me about what they
think the best policies for the methane
capture example you could do a long-term
lease so you could lease out the
operation of the wastewater treatment
for 50 years a long time and the
companies say
we could do things if we own that plant
right
in terms of you know just all these sort
of cutting-edge technologies that we
will not do even with a 50-year lease
right 50 years is pretty long
and that's not selling the wastewater
treatment plant you're just taking a
part of it right the other thing i
learned the other day is jordan might
find this of interest i used to think
the only privately owned bridge in the
united states was the ambassador bridge
across from the u.s to canada which is
owned by a family and has duty-free and
tolls and everything else i recently
learned from one of my board members
bob hellman uh who invests in this
there's like seven or eight private
private bridges so these are bridges
they're toll bridges they're part of the
network they're they're they're
operating commercially they're operated
like a private business but there
there's some
aspect of infrastructure communications
where if you can just say it's
privatization that ends the conversation
yeah and i think that's a mistake
because economics uh actually albert
williamson who won a nobel prize in
economics uh pointed to this a lot of
these are commercial activities where
you can
you know you can have the private sector
in there operating it commercially and
you get better service quality you get
proper asset maintenance you get
incorporation of new technologies so so
so that i want to avoid the demagoguery
if you're a politician and one of the
things you want to ask yourself is like
how many things do you actually want to
be responsible that's right it's like
why not farm some of this out to
competent people it's the only way and
this is part of this efficiency issue
you know as the scale of my operations
have grown the only way i've been able
to manage that is to make sure that i
have competent people around me and then
give them their fiefdom and i do not
micromanage it's like you can either do
this or you can't if you can't i'm going
to find someone else right away because
this has to be done but if you can do it
good do it and then i can go do
something else that i can do or that i
want to do and and that that
distribution it's like why wouldn't you
capitalize on the on the uh uh
willingness of private companies to bear
some of the damn risk and to help you
with the messages
some good news for you jordan which is
trudeau has offered to privatize all of
jordan peterson corporation so
you're gonna have some he's just eager
to take it all over so that could take a
lot of work off your plate number one
yeah yeah okay the other thing here that
i was thinking about uh
rick when you were talking about this
privatization right that's another big
scary word like deregulation in certain
cases
talking about selling the roads right
right
but it but what's so ridiculous about it
as with regulation you know which i i
learned in a recent conversation how
black and white my own thinking was on
it and i've been trying to research to
kind of crack that open
but it removes all the benefit for the
huge the immense gray area in between
right of all the ways the privatization
can be there can be partial there can be
split partnership there's a hundred
different ways to skew deals and i was
thinking about what you're saying just
in
in simplest terms about how this
functions and it's like it's like when
we buy solar right i've now put solar
panels on two houses right yeah i don't
want to own it for 25 years i'd rather
the company own like we sit down and we
look at all these things you can own it
outright and you're responsible for
maintenance i don't want to be
responsible for maintenance of solar
panels like i'm a i'm i'd rather sit in
my office and type right right and so
it's like what you know there's concrete
ways that people can kind of understand
this that are in structures that are
that are all around us all the time and
so you know what's a particular interest
to me about the is the situation in
ithaca is that it's a balance between
the two right there's aspects that seem
that are privatized and there's aspects
that aren't and you know creative
structures that's the
this gets back to something that we
touched on earlier which is well what's
the proper antidote to ideological star
ideological struggle and
strategy well yeah it looks like it's
something like nuance it's like
well if you specify the problem look let
me tell you something
for
for professors that were negotiating for
with the university for their grant
application like their initial startup
grant before they go to grant
i said look if you want to maximize the
amount of money the university is going
to give you
detail out all of the equipment you need
with the costs like down to thousand
dollars 500 100 make a detailed list and
get everything you want and you will get
every cent and the reason for that is
well how are they going to say no it's
like you don't need this piece of 500
equipment
no
of course that's that's not going to
happen now if you ask for 500 000
they're going to say how about 250 but
if you do a detailed summary of
everything you need for your research
down to the micro details it's like you
just get it
and it's the same thing here it's like
it could easily be that if we find
ourselves in general in a conversation
that's tilting in an ideological
direction what that means is we've got
the level of analysis specified you know
or we're dealing with with bad faith
players but we might just have the level
of analysis improperly specified
because who's going to argue with the
methane plant you know who's going to
argue with that also lack of
after-action reports meaning that you
know you have new orleans blow out and
everybody knows about it but if it
doesn't nobody's going to hear about it
and i think that there's a failure in
in messaging to prescribe the roads not
taken and failures that are averted and
potential expenses and costs for it so
like how useful would it be for somebody
to say i put this much money into
reinforcing a bridge this hurricane came
it didn't get knocked down here's how
many people would be delayed for how
long here's the expense that we would
have here is what would happen to
insurance premiums and we need to figure
out how to convey back to people because
i think that you know that's a corny
problem because prevention is a lot less
sexy than cure right it's really a big
problem because the thing is that most
well most things work all the time and
so pointing to something and saying hey
look at how that's working it's like
well yeah almost everything works thank
god for that but it's it's very
difficult for people to get people
excited about predictability even though
that's what everybody wants it's the
same rules that you're talking about
with nuance though because how you get
people excited is specifics right so
right there's a hurricane that came
through it was you know i don't know how
hurricanes are rated here's what would
have happened to the bridge here's what
that means in concrete terms like
there's a way to spell a narrative that
everybody can feel good about it i mean
one of the things that we're looking at
increasingly in
in
messaging and politics is is
what's called like the good boy good
girl effect that people are so exhausted
from being told that they do anything
right right they feel like they're
killing themselves they're working
they're trying to stay up with groceries
they're trying to follow rules when
people aren't they're trying to play by
the rules
you know be law abiding and no one's
coming along telling them that they're
doing a good job and i think that this
yeah they're saying often instead that
they're participants they're unwitting
participants in a corrupt and malevolent
system that's doomed for failure
yeah great i'm breaking my back to do
this and that's the message
some motivation likewise with
infrastructure right it's do we want
another catastrophe the bridges are
crumbling there's all this stuff and i
think that that a shot of
of a of an after action report about
some innovation that got made and to
detail its success gives people some
role in agency
in their interaction it brings
government back to them it brings the
notions of infrastructure and their city
functioning around them back to them as
opposed to everything well and it's not
like you americans don't like success
stories
because you do you know i mean well one
of the things that's really interesting
from a canadian perspective to go down
to the us is how cinematic the culture
is like everything's like a big movie
new york city is like that it's like
it's just cinematic everywhere and your
culture is immensely powerful in
generating motivational narratives
it's it's second to none in that and
everyone ever all right well that's why
america is so dominant culturally
and so much of the messaging is positive
it's it's success i mean look at the
marvel movies just as an example that's
a multi-billion dollar franchise and
that's all aiming upward like it's all
positive you're so good at that it's
just ridiculous and it and so it doesn't
seem to me to be impossible to do
something like celebration of well this
methane treatment plant for example and
to elevate it up to to
elevate it up to something worthy of of
genuine and deep admiration because it
really is that it is that it's like how
good is that yeah let me see so good
about greg's point it's it's a really
good point about about messaging and
again you know this this is um i think
the the disconnect between the
engineering and the communications
people because the engineers will report
the improvements in terms of metrics
they'll say well well we get you know so
many hundreds of cars per hour across
this lane with this new facility you
know and that that doesn't
it doesn't sell you know but but that's
not a story the story is the story is a
single mother who can now get to work
and back for your kids an hour earlier
that's this right and then you talk
about that in terms of how many hours a
week and how many hours a year and what
that time spent with kids like what she
was able to do with her family that she
couldn't yes precisely that yes yes and
engineers well the thing there's a
reason for that too you know because
engineers are temperamentally different
from those who would communicate so
engineers are fundamentally interested
in things yes that's part and and the
communicative types are fundamentally
interested in people and so the
engineers are going to say they are
interested in things it's like oh here's
a bunch of things stories well that
doesn't work it's not a story yeah and
so start organizing this we'll add
methane to the marvel universe
[Music]
but the point is is this is like the
ultimate it should be the ultimate
bipartisan
you know opportunity to come together
and say look you know we we need we have
the technology we have right exactly we
have the technology that's the six
million dollar man it's not it's not a
question of developing something in a
lab it's patented it's proven it's there
it's ready to be deployed can't we just
come together and say this is a
win-win-win and then advertise somehow
figure out how to message so the joe and
jane six-pack
can say this is an improvement in our
life right we we you know
we we uh
you know inju we get benefits from this
and and you know we need to figure out a
way to help the engineers and people
actually care who are in the political
and the private realm that we do get
benefits from this because this idea
that's so cynical you know the right
looks at government and thinks oh it's
full of corrupt people only up for
themselves and then the left looks at
businesses say well it's only it's all
full of corrupt people only out for
themselves it's like it's simply not
true that is like there's corruption in
every endeavor but it's a small
percentage of the endeavor in a
functioning country and the idea that
everybody is only self-interested that's
well first of all that's a confession
not a theory and second it's simply not
true like the more people i've met the
more i've been struck by the fact that
there's so many good people working on
both sides of an argument and they're
working for high and noble
purposes i agree and high and noble
purposes exist no so no cynicism man
that's that's such a compound it's
better than naivety but in addition you
know complementary to an academic career
which you're familiar with it's been a
joy to get involved in real
infrastructure because these are people
who actually care about whether the
subways in new york work or the bus
systems you know work or the water's
clean or if wastewater treatment plants
are you know are operational i mean they
really do care right and so for me i get
site visits i get to see the stuff in
construction you can tell that they care
you can tell that they care because
they're paying attention to details that
matter they're real it's real it's
really matters if the sewage system
works and you think well that's not that
interesting it's kind of beneath me it's
like of course the sewage system is
beneath you like obviously but
it's a mark of caring to make those
things work and everyone knows what it's
like to bring a plumber into your house
who's a good plumber yep it's like
you're so happy he's there it's like
great and he's got his business and it's
going fine and he comes in and he
doesn't rip you off on the bill and he
actually fixes it and it's not going to
screw up again it's like and it's a good
interchange it's a you know you're happy
to have someone like that in your house
absolutely
and that's
problems the first time we bought a
house that i feel like
our trusted plumber was like part of the
family
like figure out his favorite his
favorite thing to drink at like cocktail
hour at the end of the day i mean he was
in there
it's unbelievable how reliant we are
yeah skilled skilled trades people
working people who do their job well
it's just it's unbelievable yeah but
take take that greg and multiply it by
ten right so one of our affiliates is
patrick foye who was the head of the new
york of the port authority of new york
and new jersey but then he was made head
of the mta
and guess what happened covet hit right
the fair box revenues of the the
mta in new york were down by like 90
and here's a guy who's been appointed by
the governor to do that
and you know this is your moment to step
up to the plate you gotta you gotta
still pay your workers you gotta keep
the system running but your fare box
revenue just dropped by ninety percent
because of the quarantine
so so think of that right i couldn't
sleep i wouldn't be able to see but
patrick was able to take it through
and pull it somehow pull it out the
other end
right and manage all this crap that was
going on on the new york city subway
system
you know partly because the virus
i mean that's amazing i was stunned when
i went to new york city to manhattan you
know it looked like it did five years
ago except it was cleaner i thought
and then i i noticed that well everybody
was just back on the streets this is
just reopened i thought how just think
about this that city was shut down for
18 months
and it still works
it's like what the hell that's a miracle
that's an absolute miracle and if
everyone was corrupt and power-seeking
and malevolent and only out for
themselves that is not how that city
would look no
no and it is amazing given the level of
activity and the density and the
restaurants and the waste and the
you know it's it's amazing it's amazing
it does work but but you know like as i
said jordan at the outset i come from
this
you know neoclassical free enterprise
kind of uh
perspective but the longer i've been
dealing with infrastructure the more
respect and admiration
i have for the public people
who have you know are dedic largely
dedicating their careers to making this
stuff work they really do have a public
interest
you know desire
embedded in them
which which is nice right it's it's nice
to see that and they they take their job
they could all make more money in the
private sector probably yeah
and be easier
you know and and the rewards would be
bigger and there might be more security
i mean look what greg and i went to
washington four years ago and one of the
things we did was host a couple of
lunches and we had relatively junior
democrat congress people and republican
congress people just come to lunch
because they don't get a chance to meet
each other partly because they're
raising money 25 hours a week and then
and plus they're up for re-election in
two years like these are busy people
right and so the first thing we did was
just had everybody introduce themselves
and talk for five minutes it was like
why are you doing this that was the
question and you could not tell the
democrats from the republicans
every story was the same was like well
you know i'm kind of a serious person
and i would really like to serve my
country and i felt that although i had
other opportunities that this was worth
a sacrifice and i was hoping i could
come to washington and really make a
difference right like you listen to
eight people say that and these aren't
trivial people and they're not
grandstanding because there's no
audience it's like they're just saying
what it is and you can be cynical about
that if you want but you're a fool if
you are because that means you're
cynical about the most noble ambitions
of of of people who are making a genuine
sacrifice these are hard jobs
and so and it's so nice to hear from you
that you've been in the trenches working
on these practical projects and the
consequence for you is that you've
become like more optimistic and and
pleased with the characters of the
people you're dealing with yes yes
let me be clear jordan there you know we
should be clear there there are cases
where infrastructure delivery is rife
with corruption and there's oda black in
brazil you may be familiar with that
scandal in south america big it's
brazilian construction company was
bribing you know public officials to to
be the winning bidder and prime
ministers went to prison you know so
it's not it's not some pure it's the
real world of humanity right it's it's
it's not a pure thing but i think that's
the exception rather than the rule well
psychopaths are three percent of the
population not 97 yeah and they never
get above five percent before they're
culled essentially one to five percent
and and the basic the the the stable
point of psychopathy prevalence is three
percent and so the idea that it's just
malevolent power seeking that drives
hierarchical organizations it's just
wrong in the face of it because
otherwise there'd be way more
psychopaths and they'd be way more
successful
so so yeah these are exceptions
especially in highly functioning
societies and the us i mean there isn't
a society that's ever been more highly
functioning than the u.s all things
considered wow so i'm glad to hear that
well i don't think it's i don't i don't
think that's an unreasonable proposition
i mean
it's an it's the economic driver in some
sense of innovation throughout the free
world i mean there's other countries
that are doing well but you know the
amer america is really a kind of
epicenter and everyone knows it and so
it's and it's huge i mean 300 million
people that that's a lot of middle class
people man well there is no silicon
valley of germany right i mean
to some extent right
right well in silicon yeah silicon
valley candidate countries
do
can do beautifully for sure i mean the
thing that people tend to forget about
america is it's like all of europe in
one place i mean like the disparate
cultures
climates you know perspectives values
communities that are held together it's
pretty extraordinary i mean that's
another and the diversity of government
and the distribution of powers it's a
complex place and so the fact that it
functions as well it is as it does all
the time i mean and a good index of that
you don't think your systems are
functioning well they well have you
plugged something into your outlet in
your house lately
and has it how often does that not work
and that's a complicated system almost
always works i i do want to tell you
maybe jordan will appreciate this a
european friend um
she was from austria came to
new york right um you know to visit it
was it was her first time
and um you know
she had uh you know her reaction
was america she said americans aren't
anything
and i couldn't understand what what she
was saying she said americans aren't and
this was after her visit she said
americans aren't anything what she meant
is
you know it's they're not
in new york right they're not just latin
they're not asian they're not it's like
this big mishmash right it's like a u.n
meeting
so so you know if you look at new york
city of course it's different across the
country but a lot of places there's no
unique
you know it's a bunch of cultures thrown
in together we lit my wife and i lived
at 55th and 9th avenue in hell's kitchen
for five years i think there were 15
different ethnic restaurants within a
short walk
of our of our unit
right so it's this big mess
what upsets me probably more than
anything with the way that the the
cultural conversation has gotten so
tribalized is that it removes the
conversations about
diversity
from being joyful and there's so many
ways that it's it's such a driver of joy
when when
when when you have
friends and community and family and
food and culture and music from across
all of these different categories and
yeah i'm finding people are increasingly
constrained about how they even know how
to talk about that is the one thing you
know and then the other thing is of
course not to detour us off into
cultural territory because i know jordan
gets really uncomfortable discussing
those things publicly um
but you know people people also start to
start to view it that there's like one
set of spokes people from every
community like i know people who only
know woke latinos like how limited is
your world if the only people who who
you know are one particular
cross-section of a community yeah
and so they're so diverse craig the the
co-oh yeah they're from belize they're
from honduras they're from mexico i mean
and they're they're all quite they're
panama you know costa rica i mean i'm
shocked at how if you talk to those
folks how differently they view
themselves
right
that was one of the the great um joys of
doing
political out you know i did a lot of
political outreach and conversations
ramping up to 2020 but it's like you
know top people talk about you know just
use for an example the hispanic vote
it's like are we talking california
versus texas versus cuban americans
versus argentina like
there's such a range and there's so much
there's so much like what troubles me so
much is the dampening down
of the discussion in ways that are
joyful because that's always what wins
hearts and minds is what wins you know
the biggest thing that well i won't get
on a i won't get on a soapbox so let's
go back to some concrete realities so to
speak given we're talking about
infrastructure right rick
priorities like that's always difficult
what what's really broken that should be
fixed like first and for the biggest
bang for the environment and for and for
efficiency in your estimation well so so
jordan there's a couple of big projects
that that just must be done the gate you
visit in new york the gateway tunnel
about a 13 billion dollar project
they're the rail tunnels that run under
the hudson river and they're owned by
amtrak
but new jersey transit uses them during
the peak commute there's about one train
per minute that goes through there they
are over 100 years old probably 110
they are um
in dire need of being uh improved just
there's a new alignment just being
almost replaced eastside access jordan
in in new york is the long island
railroad coming into the city there's
there's a huge project that needs to
uh
to streamline that
um there's a rail tunnel in baltimore
city where i'm from that's from the
civil war that's too low for the uh
trains to go through because it was
designed during the civil war and that
that needs to be raised so i would say a
few of these let's say mega projects
need to be done the second thing jordan
is um
deferred maintenance we just need to to
upgrade
it could be airports it could be dans it
could be levees it could be seaports it
could be electrical systems i mean just
a crop we need to prioritize where
deferred maintenance has gotten to be
you know a huge problem
and you know and address that and the
third one jordan i'd say is is we need
to have some initiative greg could help
with this some initiative to have a not
not a
developing technology but an adoption of
technology just like a wave of
technological adoption and
infrastructure and you know there's all
this stuff where people you know are
they're aware of this new this
technology and the latest app and all
that sort of stuff but all of this um a
lot of the stuff that we've been talking
about with smart stoplights smart street
lights i could do go on about liners for
water pipes that will renovate water
pipes that attend the cost
there needs to be some broad initiative
maybe we could do it with
when the president signs the bill
to say let's just have a big initiative
focused on this
this is the ultimate bipartisan thing
because it will reduce greenhouse gas it
will reduce you know uh d soil emissions
are horrible
gas emissions are bad it will improve
the efficiency of our infrastructure and
it's there on the table it's just
somehow we can back maybe backstop the
risk of the asset owners whether it's a
county or a city or a state or whoever
it is the city
backstop their wrists somehow i don't
know let's just have some
initiative
to help these folks get the technology
adopted and jordan i would say that's
number one all right great i think
that's a good place to stop i hope that
we can have a conversation like this
again and and also to talk more
maybe
we can organize this in some manner
about how to ally
the proper direction of the
infrastructure project with the
messaging so and we've outlined some of
that today which i thought was extremely
useful and so thank you very much both
of you for participating today and uh
definitely let's talk again maybe in a
month month and a half or something like
that
great great
this was a pleasure thank you rick good
to meet you greg good to meet you thanks
greg i'm happy to talk at any time
[Music]
you